[Music]
January 2016 German police raid homes
across the country as part of a move to
take down an international human
trafficking network it's the fastest
growing crime in the world but sights
like this a rare
this is 21st century crime hard to track
low risk and high reward for the
criminal gangs behind it they're making
$250,000 a year just one girl they're
making millions off of 10 to 15 today's
biggest criminals could be trafficking
humans drugs or weapons the authorities
charged with stopping them have found
some unlikely new partners banks
identifying the proceeds of criminal
activity is an extremely complicated
business and it's something when arms
race because obviously as we get better
detection criminals get better at
evading now technology companies are
also disrupting the world of crime what
this technology does is allow someone to
truly follow the money it was stored a
random chance before now we're really
following the money
[Music]
Canada has a huge problem with human
trafficking a crime which comes in many
forms but always coercing moving and
exploiting its victims for financial
gain here 60% of victims are under 18
Tamir was trafficked from Hungary to
Canada age 21 she understands the
mindset of the traffickers who often go
undetected with in familiar surroundings
such as shopping malls usually miles are
a pretty popular place for for young
girls to hang out this is when they come
during lunchtime after school but
unfortunately the traffickers also know
where they hang out with so traffickers
come here as well a trafficker will
spend a week or two watching girls
before he targets the most vulnerable
one paying her attention and making her
feel special you don't need a lot of
time to make a teenager girl fall in
love with you normally it takes less
than 2 weeks for the girl to be taken
away from her family a lot of loved ones
and being trafficked
the traffic has moved the girls out of
state then the real manipulation begins
he gets around drugs and he invites his
friends over and they come into the room
and normally this is what they do it's a
formula and she would look at him and
say what do you want me to do with your
friends and he's like what please me
she's confused but she wants to please
him
so she starts doing things with his
friends it's all part of the traffickers
plan to trap the girl and he films it so
the next morning she may feel remorse
and say I don't understand what's going
on I just want to go home and he may say
you want to go home
why didn't I put this on your Instagram
or Facebook show everybody what kind of
a [ __ ] you are and she would be like no
please don't
what do you want me to do and he's like
what there's a crime next door go and
take care of him and leave the manana I
love that girls can be resold making the
traffickers millions to the traffickers
their commodities and Tamir knows
firsthand the extent the criminals will
go to to hold on to them she was forced
to work in Canada's sex industry one of
the story they always told us if we
leave they'll take all the baseball bat
that's already had bloodstains from
other girls and they've hit us in the
back of our head and and the back and
the legs and then we'll collapse and
they'll beat us till we are black and
blue and they'll look they will put our
body in a black garbage bag and then
they put our body in the Lake Ontario
and they will take our passport and send
it back with another girl and no one
will ever know what happened to us they
told us that story every single day
Toronto is Canada's human trafficking
hub 885 reported cases here over the
last four years are likely just a
glimpse at the full scale of the problem
Detective Sergeant nun geo tramonto's e
heads up the Toronto Police Service
human trafficking enforcement team it's
a crime that doesn't spare any ethnicity
or any nationality these pimps
traffickers see the vulnerability and
they expose it and they pounce on it and
then they sell these girls a dream and
unfortunately isn't a dream it's a
nightmare
like many 21st century crimes it's
hidden from sight within communities and
away from the streets which makes it one
of the hardest crimes to fight because
the girls are scattered throughout the
city they don't stay in one place very
long they will have a female victim and
state two or three days do their
business put up their ads and then leave
the only way police can find the girls
is trawling through online ads it's
evolved with technology everything's
hidden behind a computer now that has
enabled the pimps to be anonymous in
this one it says daddy's little a lot of
victims call their traffickers daddy
what my officer is gonna do is going to
try to make a date with her and see if
we can communicate with her she said hey
babe yes I'm available and it's $200 an
hour I'll ask her what time undercover
officers spend thousands of man hours
conversing with and texting with girls
but even if they find them the girls are
often too afraid to testify against
their traffickers
having escaped her captors Tamia set up
a safe house for trafficked girls and
became an activist in six years she saw
500 court cases lead to only 18
convictions but everything changed
after she was invited to look at the
bank statements of a trafficked girl I
looked at their transactions and the
details and I said to myself good lord
this could have helped in so many
investigations that's black and white
evidence right there that the victim is
making the money but she's not spending
it on herself Tamia saw thousands of
dollars deposited into the girls account
and every few days the amount was
transferred to the trafficker realizing
that the way to find the criminals was
to follow the money
- mayor decided to follow the money men
she stood up at a national conference
for bankers and shared her life story I
need your help like can anybody can
anybody promise me that none of you
heard my story and now you know how
powerful can you be can you just promise
me that you're gonna join us in this
fight it's all Canadian bankers so one
hand goes up at the front and this man
gets up when he says very quietly my
boss doesn't know this yet but sign me
up
that man was Peter Warrick director of
anti-money laundering risk intelligence
at the Bank of Montreal it was a wake-up
call to me I mean we're in the heart of
the financial district we're in the
middle of the five major banks in Canada
that control the bulk of the finances in
Canada and the bulk of the transactions
that are occurring through bank accounts
and things like that you know the amount
of information any bank holds is
incredible
within a month Peter had Canada's top
five banks and the financial regulator
on board and projects protect was
launched prior to December 2015 I didn't
have a clue that we had a problem with
human trafficking in Canada so I learned
me very quickly and as I learned and
others learn we found new indicators
which we immediately shared with each
other the bankers started looking for
patterns among customers transactions
that could identify the behavior of a
sex trafficker certain suspicious
activities like a string of late night
deposits into multiple ATM machines
would indicate that a bank should take a
closer look at an account if they found
deposits from different states multiple
bookings of hotels taxis or payments for
online advertising the chances were they
could be looking at the account of a
trafficker and then they would share the
data with law enforcement
in 2017 this approach helped the police
to crack an international trafficking
ring leading to the rescue of nine
Portuguese girls and the arrest of two
traffickers involved in funneling over 3
million dollars to Europe in just 12
months reports on human trafficking from
Canada's banks to the police increased
by three hundred and fifty percent but
that's just the tip of the iceberg
[Music]
globally human trafficking is estimated
to be worth a hundred and fifty billion
dollars a year and all that money has to
end up somewhere
these are some of the ill-gotten gains
from a web of criminal activity that
takes in the trafficking of humans
weapons and illegal drugs we've seen
some weird and wonderful assets things
like gold bars which were a quarter of a
million pounds each and nearly two and a
half million pounds of the gold bullion
things like the five hundred and fifty
ton cargo vessels the luxury yachts the
motor cruisers that are filled in lined
with cocaine and we're selling a yacht
next week that was used and a very
tragic case to smuggle illegal
immigrants into the country former tax
investigator Aidan Larkin leads the team
at Wilson's auction house in Belfast
Northern Ireland today they're selling
off over a quarter of a million pounds
worth of property from convicted
criminals proceeds from auctions like
this a return to the public purse to
fund law enforcement and to compensate
victims Aiden's team works with police
forces across the EU often helping seize
the assets of the criminals who've been
caught trying to clean up their dirty
money the star of the show the 911 GTS
should fetch anywhere in the region
every 80,000 pounds an estimated two to
four trillion dollars of illicit funds
are laundered each year much of it by
organized crime networks operating
across borders nowadays you can walk
through an airport and for example if
someone was to say to the the border
official it's an Audemars Piguet watch
there's only a select amount of people
that actually know what that watch is
some of the watches are Richard Mille a
watch with a rubber strap is worth
250,000 pounds so we've seen a few quite
a few cases where people who are wanting
to move money between jurisdictions in
and out of different countries will
simply convert that cash and convert
that asset sell the big asset sell the
mansion and turn it into one expensive
watch here people can bid on the spoils
that have been captured but mostly
criminals who launder money at
away with it year only 1% of illicit
funds worldwide are even identified in
the UK Europe and America banks have
come under ever greater pressure from
regulators to root out the dirty money
in their systems for a long time results
were mixed over a nine-year period
financial institutions were fined a
total of over 321 billion dollars for
failing to do enough some even fell foul
of the law themselves we are here today
to announce the filing of criminal
charges against HSBC bank both its US
entity HSBC u.s. and the parent HSBC
group for its sustained and systemic
failure to guard against the corruption
of our financial system by drug
traffickers and other criminals and for
evading us sanctions law hsbc one of the
world's largest banking groups admitted
it had failed to prevent drug cartels
from laundering at least 881 million
dollars in trafficking proceeds through
the bank in a deferred prosecution
agreement with the US Department of
Justice the bank accepted it
knowingly engaged in conduct and
practices that allowed sanctioned
entities in the Middle East and
elsewhere to move money
HSBC paid a settlement of over 1.9
billion dollars an unprecedented amount
but equivalent to just five weeks worth
of the bank's global profits the public
perception of banks has obviously not
been great over the last few years and
an HSBC as a firm particularly has
understands the consequences falling
short when it comes to financial crime
risk management
I hope the work we're doing can
challenge that perception because you
know we're working continuously with law
enforcement to tackle issues like human
trafficking identifying the proceeds of
criminal activity is an extremely
complicated business sophisticated
criminals so ones who are involved in
large-scale human trafficking and other
criminal activity
they've developed their techniques over
many years and we have to try and
identify that we see layers of front
companies so as money comes into the
financial system it'll come into one
organization and that it will be moved
around many layers of front companies
before it finally arrives at its
intended destination
every day 1.2 billion transactions take
place in the global financial system
faced with the prospect of more big
fines banks have increasingly erred on
the side of caution by flagging any
transactions that look vaguely
suspicious we as an institution would
always err on the side of reporting
rather not reporting and of course that
brings with it challenges as well as
benefits too much information can be as
challenging as not enough Britain's
National Crime Agency receives over four
hundred thousand reports of suspicious
financial activity every year eighty
percent of which are from banks the
agency's economic crimes command has the
unenviable task of identifying the
actual criminals money flowing through
the financial system it is very much
looking for a needle in a haystack and
not only are we looking for a needle
haystack we're looking for that in a
globalized world where organized crime
has become more sophisticated where
communications have become more
sophisticated and where the financial
services provided have become ever more
sophisticated a more sophisticated
problem has demanded a more
sophisticated response in 2015 British
law enforcement and banks came together
to form the joint money-laundering
intelligence task force there was a step
change the top of the banks with the
CEOs and their boards in recognising
that they were willing to and wanted to
work closely with law enforcement and
there was a step change certainly in law
enforcement and I was very much involved
with that when we were saying actually
we want to and need to work with the
banks to build a new relationship built
on a trust and confidence where we
overcome those barriers where we share
read information about real people doing
real crimes
many banks signaled they were keen to
help but their own systems remained a
blunt tool around 90% of banks alerts of
suspicious activity were actually
entirely innocent far from finding
criminals they were more often blocking
legitimate customers
[Music]
but a new generation of financial
technology or FinTech companies are
emerging intent on providing a solution
david mclaughlin heads one of them doing
anything that I could do to to help make
it harder for criminals to move their
money around the world it was something
that was important to me in an
unassuming suburban office quanta vers
has developed machine learning
technology that is already being used by
some of the world's biggest banks what
this technology does is allow someone to
truly follow the money it was sort of
random chance before now we're really
following the money the team here is
training the company's computer system
to identify potential criminal activity
on its own every day it is finding new
ways that criminals are changing their
behavior and every day it's identifying
those and and learning from those to be
able to catch it when it happens again
the next day fed initially with several
years worth of data from a major global
bank controversies system learnt what
both legitimate and suspicious business
activities look like so this was a
dashboard that the application would
generate after it's run a sentimental
the application looks at factors
including how much money is being moved
how quickly and to where as it searches
for patterns and anomalies normally we
would expect to see in this case you
know a ship that's getting ready to go
out to sea they would stock up with babe
do all the maintenance all the food
everything they needed to do and you'd
see a spike in this particular case we
see that the dollar values that were
leaving the account were significantly
less than what we would have expected
from a normal ship behaving in this
fashion and so when we drill into the
details fuel cost maintenance costs
operational expenses and so forth were
all as expected but the payroll was much
lower than we would have expected and so
that then is a tip-off that there might
be some human trafficking or slavery
involved
analyzing just eight different
characteristics generates over 61
million permutations for the system to
evaluate as it identifies the bad guys
each of these things then get linked
together in a network that allows us to
see how they're connected to one another
so individuals companies we can see what
information about each of them we can
see information about the nature of the
relationships between the parties and
then we can also begin to identify
so-called communities controversies
software flagged suspicious behavior
around one such community in Panama a
year later one of the parties was under
arrest and being described as one of the
world's most significant drug money
launderers but the technology is still
in its infancy it's only as good as the
data it gets fed and there are often
heavy restrictions on banks sharing data
outside their own area of operation the
trouble is 21st century crime knows no
such limits
Thailand is one of the world's largest
seafood exporters it's a 6.5 billion
dollar business one that exploits many
of the estimated 425 thousand people in
modern slavery in this country many are
trafficked by large criminal networks
across several international borders
cemaat was promised a job as a security
guard in a Thai fishing port but instead
he was drugged
oh god I didn't even call yeah yeah yeah
I'm an illegal act you give a good call
my work on a new Singapore in Calais
oh god I'm Cornelia collaborative I Kate
English yeah we're a black bar sir Mart
had been trafficked he would be trapped
on the boat effectively enslaved for the
next eight years
tomorrow condemned man God live look at
me Sam busy quarter local in column with
Hamilton come now it'll be may survive
in cave in cabin along local torment man
the moment a man called Utah mikata to a
keypad keep a corner with the one
quality I remember
sir Mart was ultimately able to take his
captors to court but most survivors
can't the criminals are left to continue
their activity elsewhere in Thailand of
the estimated 16 million forced labor
victims worldwide only 1038 cases were
prosecuted in 2016
disrupting criminal activity on this
scale depends on knowing exactly where
to look for evidence and finding a way
to get the data to the banks and their
FinTech partners that's where this woman
comes in arch Nakata a Hong kong-based
lawyer is on her way to meet local
contacts with first-hand information
about trafficking in Thailand
she works for Liberty Asia an NGO
dedicated to bridging the crucial gap
between what the locals know and the
bank's computer systems are missing it's
a potent to have the eyes and ears on
the ground and to be able to take that
information from the front line and to
share it with people who are on the
front desk millions of miles away making
decisions that are so critical to this
business
Liberty Asia has built a network of
contacts in 32 NGOs across Southeast
Asia to find and share information this
morning arch nur is meeting a man who
could be an important addition to that
Network Sam pong Sergei Oh heads up a
workers rights group that's become the
first port of call for trafficked
fishermen
what percentage of victims you've worked
with have actually been able to take the
case forward and how many of those have
resulted in successful the victims
wellness and Kadima kid Obama we do this
Iranian common policy person may meet up
in your common the million in families
don't even brought up commerce under God
they put mocha into electron I perceive
I saw pie - out and hallelujah merits
out in Phuket and thinking local
children were man million will put me
upon Taunton we were talking car who
McCain bizarre sort longing for me your
understanding complex local factors like
corruption is one key piece of the
intelligence picture arch nur and her
partner's try to build another comes via
contacts with the people who really know
how things work mr. J is an extra [ __ ]
who has brought hundreds of people from
neighboring countries to the Thai
fishing industry man in it man Tokyo
Morgan it is today is Punk's idea
little on man
Salani a looming container good zombie
they need poo
no Pete you know Jan Koller nanny look
like my homie Lou
how many with all these insights help
the NGOs build an intimate understanding
of how the criminal networks operate
[Music]
hold up near some fancy funding here
as the picture on the ground becomes
clearer the NGOs flag up local court
cases so that Liberty Asia can gather
hard data the names of the arrested and
prosecuted it then makes them accessible
to over 9,000 banks globally and to key
technology partners like controverse so
this is an email that we received from
Liberty Asia they send us information
about bad guys that they've found and so
those names of those individuals are now
in our database and so anytime there's a
transaction in the future any time we
see a transaction regardless where it
comes from we're scanning against the
database that we've been collecting of
people and so those three people are in
there now forever and immutable we if
they ever do some transaction through
some financial services organization
we're going to know it if it's client of
ours and we're gonna see them and we're
going to understand that those people
are engaged in human trafficking back in
Bangkok arch nur is reviewing Liberty
Asia's latest detailed analysis of human
trafficking networks to take directly to
the banks where we see all of this
information cascading into is a place
where banks are safe
you know we now understand what this
looks like on the ground so now we're in
a more informed position to make
decisions about accounts and to be able
to collaborate with law enforcement on
investigations technological innovation
is driving these new partnerships but
it's also helping many of the groups
they're targeting across the world
criminals themselves are constantly
exploring the latest tools like crypto
currencies that will help them keep
their money online and off the grid it's
a technological arms race between them
and the men and women on their tail it
is that cat-and-mouse game you know it's
very important for the banks the police
to adapt to new and evolving technology
because if we don't adapt to that
technology we're gonna let be left
behind and traffickers are going to be
able to do their their work without any
consequence
21st century criminals can operate in
the shadows more easily than ever before
their crimes may be hard to spot but the
impact isn't bringing misery pain and
death to millions of victims around the
world new opportunities to disrupt those
crimes could be the key to finally
bringing some relief to those whose
lives are ruined
[Music]
you